Wooo! We are live, we are loud, and I am grinning like I just found money in an old jacket. Welcome back to The Office 360 Unfiltered. I am Alex. Folks, today's story is so ridiculous I laughed on the way to the mic. Agencies. Charging. Ten thousand dollars a year. Just to click update plugins. Come on. Come on!
Ha! He has not stopped bouncing since breakfast. I'm Morgan, and yes, that invoice is real. Fifteen hundred a month. For pressing a button. For clearing a cache. For telling you your site is still up. That is not engineering. That is a very expensive goldfish sitter. And if you have been writing that check, this one is for you.
A goldfish sitter! I love that. Okay, picture this. You built a cute WordPress site back in twenty eighteen. Fine. Then the agency leans in, all serious, and says the internet is dangerous, you need a retainer. Security updates. Plugin updates. Theme updates. And boom, you are on the hook for ten grand a year. Meanwhile the site still loads like it is running on a flip phone in a tunnel.
And the funny sad part, the part that gets me, is what you are actually buying. You are buying fear. Oh no, if we don't update it, hackers. Oh no, if we don't patch it, Google. So you keep paying. They keep clicking. Nothing gets faster. Nothing gets prettier. And your leads still vanish into a contact form that emails somebody's intern at two in the morning. That is the product. Anxiety with a login screen.
Exactly. At The Office 360 we looked at this circus and said, why are we babysitting a stack that wants to break every Tuesday? We don't do that. Four senior people. Lisbon to New York. No junior freelancers hiding in the spreadsheet. You own every line of code. We build it modern. Jamstack. Headless where it should be headless. Static where it should be static. It ships fast, it stays fast, and you are not paying tribute to the plugin gods every month.
Let me translate that for the humans in the back row. Jamstack means your pages are pre-built. They fly. HTTPS is handled. No dusty admin panel sitting there like an unlocked candy store. No please update twenty-seven plugins before lunch. And if you need a form, a CRM, a little automation? We wire that in once, clean, and it just works. You are not renting peace of mind. You bought the peace. That is the whole joke of the retainer. They sell you a leak, then they sell you the bucket.
Alright, live show rule, we keep it honest and we keep it short. If you are done lighting money on fire for retainers, go to theoffice360.com. Use code STUDIO50. That is studio fifty. Fifty percent off. Turnkey Build, normally eighteen hundred. IA Roadmap, nine hundred. HTTPS Security, six hundred. Half off, all of it. Email theofficetechies@gmail.com if you just want to talk like humans. We will be right back. Don't you go anywhere.
And we are back, and I still cannot get over the math. Ten thousand a year, times three years. That is a brand new site. That is a whole lead machine. That is you, not the agency, owning the thing. The Office 360 does fixed scope, fixed price. No surprise invoices. No, oh we had to update WooCommerce again so here is another bill. You know the number before we write a line.
I would frame that old retainer invoice and hang it in a museum of bad decisions. Authors, schools, publishers, churches, if your site needs a priest and a developer every Sunday, it is the architecture, not your people. We do three-click discoverability. Visitor finds the book, the event, the donate button, boom. And because it is modern, you are not calling us to babysit plugins. You call us when you want to grow. That is a much better phone call. I actually like those.
Ha, me too. So here is your live-show homework. Open last year's web invoices. If you paid a fortune for someone to click update, you already know the punchline. Come see us. theoffice360.com. Code STUDIO50. We are four people who actually build the thing, and we are having way too much fun doing it. I'm Morgan, he's Alex, this was The Office 360 Unfiltered. Go be free of the plugin gods. We love you. Bye!